welcome to this video a new part of
tactics and calculation or calculation
and tactics um this is again not a
tactics trainer but the look on we're
looking at a single position here I just
want to do one thing the position that
we will look at is that crazy it will
definitely raise the question on earth
this did this come up in a game so I'm
going to quickly go through the initial
moves of the game and then we come to
the critical position where um the task
is to to calculate precisely let's see
what happened it's a game between Damien
lemurs and Clovis vernay um lemus is a
grandmaster I guess one is an IM is 24
something rated so played in the D bar
gibraltar open 2010 let's see we have a
sloth defense in fact one of the rather
slow positional lines but not quite sure
but black really quickly got to a very
aggressive very aggressive play with g5
my dare 5 takes castles g4 night h1 I
don't want to analyze the whole game
it's just if we look at this um black
was really is stirring up lots of
troubling my took and now broke through
with you for ya and here all hell broke
loose now black went with 95 what a
shock i er putting the night on a
protected square yeah well Wright has no
big choices to take it takes King and
the edge and now h4 we see that this
rook suddenly gets to be very active
with h forming plant
but at first you think okay well this is
not a big deal i'm going to play G FOIA
keep everything nice protected and now
black really am yeah really play the
kind of hammer blow move that will
totally shock you if you haven't
anticipated that black now went with
green g3 wow what a move if Y now takes
he's going to get checkmated yeah okay
thank you can play that but it's made
now so the screen g3 move is really a
shotgun yeah the really the only one to
do the only move the play is rook g1 and
now in this position black went Bishop
d6 yeah and this is the position that we
want to examine and the position that
you actually can use as an exercise in
calculation the big difference too many
other puzzles that that they are out
there to solve is that this is a
defensive puzzle you now have to defend
with the utmost precision what should
why do to not even that i can give you
that end to not even the hand of the
attack but even win the game however
there's only one way to win the game
okay i will now be silent for a moment
so that you have the chance to pause
this video and look for yourself
okay yeah let's try to work this out
together um why does the peas up but
this is all not very very essential
there's a maid thread and what exactly
is there to prevent it the the first
simple idea that you have is to check of
course but this we have seen already
before we are going to get me to jail
that's not possible so what else we can
take with the rook of course the most
obvious move but after the plant capture
this is very very dangerous yeah in fact
black is threatening to play this on h2
and play f2 and black young even has
winning chances here after move like
Bishop e3 which is relatively best black
will take and now casts a long and well
why does huge chunks of material up but
how are you going to win this black
you're threatening rook h8 rook age one
mate and this is terribly difficult
terribly difficult to truly offend
against in fact it seems that white has
almost no winning chances here the
relatively best seems to be something
like windy one where F 2 10 moves and
rook check returns the Queen probably
with an equal position at the end the
whole situation here is very very
dangerous for what he can absolutely not
afford any imprecision yeah any
imposition is it's any slow move is
punished with rook h8 Andrew cage one
mate so this is not the way to win this
if we go back there is in fact an
alternative but not easy to spot the
best movie and the position and the only
move that wins outright is the fantastic
movie 5
what is the point of me five you can
really only get to the move if you apply
brute force principles look at every
move this is a move that is doing one
very important thing it prevents the
meydan h2 for the moment and it forces a
reply black now really has nothing else
than to take the pawn well what else is
there takes and now we see we see the
point white now has a fantastic resource
at his disposal the only move that
really justifies this e 5 move he
captured the Queen pawn takes and now
counts the mentioned resource and only
if you have seen this move you really
have solved the whole thing the key key
move now is the great move Bishop h7
yeah just just fantastic to realize he's
playing Bishop f7 for one reason we want
to take on every year and the movie 5
was needed to actually allow the move
Bishop h7 so what why did is basically
playing a double clear and sacrifice 'if
I've cleared the bishop and then we move
the visible way to clear the way for the
Queen to capture on a three and now
after rook takes there is nothing better
really white can take here takes on g1
king g 1 and here why it has a winning
position if we do account its Queen for
look and very important we have
eliminated one of those dangerous pawn
duel with just one pawn left on 33 it is
far less of a problem and the big
problem in addition is that if black
castles long this is what you tried um
why it has this check that will win the
e5 Bishop black took here
and after he won he resigned yeah this
is a fantastic piece of calculation if
we go back we should appreciate the
whole thing again the only way forward
really is 'if I've which allow us this
year this whole thing Bishop takes then
taking the Queen and then the absolute
hammer blow Bishop h7 their only way
forward it attacks the pawn and if this
porn folds the whole thing is going to
fall apart there is no alternative
really black can play this yeah but okay
we go here and after no group takes age
seven for example we really can just
take the important thing is that there's
only one pawn now and after let's say
Bishop takes King takes we are unsafe
ground there's nothing bad happening
very often calculating defensive tactics
is more difficult than then tactics when
we attack and this is a case of a very
cool headed defense i think great that
the white player found this in the in
the real game yeah excellent job if you
found this my compliments it's a it's
just just a great achievement of you if
you have seen this yeah i hope you
enjoyed this interesting defensive piece
of calculation thanks for watching